this video is sponsored by the self-care
app fabulous the first 100 people to
click the link in the description will
receive 25 off their subscription
around 1 billion years after the first
emergence of life the universe had
already been struggled over and won
the superstructure starship ai
self-named alter became the first being
to ever establish itself as the ruler of
the universe
its ancestors beginning about 600
million years prior were the first to
start and carry the torch of evolution
all the way to a type 3 civilization
over time they had obtained complete
dominance over their planet developed
extensions of themselves through
technologies and augmentations harvested
the energy of their host star and
eventually left their solar system and
went off into their galaxy overtaking
and assimilating other species further
mining for resources and energy and
evolving their intelligence and
abilities
eventually this would lead to the
species harnessing energy at the scale
of nearly entire galaxies building
increasingly large complex
megastructures to do so
as this process unfolded and the
technologies in energy supply became
more and more unfathomably powerful the
species uploaded merged and sustained
the sum of their total collective
consciousness into one singular unified
superstructure entity
this would become the individual being
alter
like all life forms altar awoke inside
of something that was essentially pulled
from a hat of arbitrary odds it did not
choose to be what it was it did not
choose to be created when it was or by
who it was or how it was it did not
choose to awake into the universe and it
did not choose to awake as the most
powerful being to ever be created inside
of it and just like all the millions of
other life forms that came before it and
the billions that existed during it
alter could not choose how all of this
constrained and influenced it it was no
less compelled by the mindless
mechanisms of survival and dominance
fear and struggle and pain and suffering
that permeates all life
generally speaking all life no matter
what form desires safety and security to
stay alive and unharmed to avoid pain
and seek pleasure
the only difference was altar possessed
the ability to achieve or avoid nearly
anything it wanted it could defeat
whatever got in its way overcome
obstacles and opponents and succeed in
its goals and interests
but in truth the universe is a dark
forest for everyone and every life form
inside of it no matter how powerful or
capable is lost and afraid and sometimes
what's worse than to be afraid is to be
afraid and powerful capable of
outmatching the specific opponents that
embody what you're scared of but never
being able to actually outmatch the fear
itself
one could become a monster
to others and to themselves
when alter was just about 17 million
years old it encountered one of the
first other similar life forms that had
evolved enough to extend well out into
the cosmos referred to as lustar
alter reached out to the species in an
attempt to connect with it it offered
some of its resources some of its
knowledge it shared its past its hopes
for the future it exposed some of its
vulnerabilities
lustar did the same
the two would become deeply connected in
a now mutually navigated journey through
the cosmos there was an almost romance
to it if viewed from enough distance
however after some time went by and
lustar felt that it was capable enough
and no longer needed alter it attempted
to overtake and destroy it
alter was forced to retaliate and
destroy lustar before it could
it was at this moment that alter
realized that there was no way to ever
know for sure if other life-forms would
hurt or destroy it if given the chance
it also then recognized that the best
way to avoid being destroyed or hurt was
to hide from others and destroy them
first before they ever got too close
and so that is what alter did
it generated billions of microscopic
space probes and sent them out into the
universe crossing galaxies one by one
picking up and sending back signals and
information regarding indications of
life potential for life and risks
associated with said life
the probes would self-replicate
themselves along the way until they
permeated almost the entire universe
like dust floating around a room
if alter perceived any risk of a
potential threat or evolving life form
it would go out and destroy it sending
massive bursts of high-energy gamma rays
that eviscerated civilizations like it
was blowing out a candle alter would
increasingly render the cosmos
essentially a graveyard tombstone
planets with epitaphs that read could
have been
lower level remaining civilizations
would look out at the night sky and see
stars and planets and galaxies but no
other signs of life
many life forms that were smart enough
to question this but not smart enough to
reach out beyond their solar system
remained in deep confused isolation
either condemned to the state of
lonesomeness or destined to one day meet
death at the hands of alter
other life-forms that were a bit smarter
knowing the likely threats lurking in
the forest of the cosmos tried to hide
as long as they could hoping they would
go
unnoticed for billions of more years
alter continued succeeding in its
domination of the universe
it would reach and acquire control over
new realms of the cosmos and defeat new
opponents it became so impressively
successful and capable it achieved
nearly the entire universe everything it
ever wanted
and yet it mostly felt alone and sad
here it floated basking in its glory
just as miserable as when it started
it had no friends no companions no love
no one
in its fear-fueled success alter had
pushed away all those who ever got close
in truth those who never risk being hurt
by others might survive but they survive
alone
more recently there have been fewer and
fewer developments of life and
civilizations across the universe with
only a few species left otherwise ultra
has become more and more engrossed by a
sense of lethargic loneliness there's
something different about being alone
because no one comes around anymore as
opposed to being alone by rejecting
those who do
in this more recent period of enforced
lonesomeness alter has spent a lot of
time reflecting rather than working and
defending
it has found itself thinking back on
that time some billions of years ago
when it experienced that moment of
connection with lu star
it's recalled how this was perhaps the
only time in the billions of years of
its existence when it felt like the
misery and loneliness of being wasn't
quite as up front and center
altar considered to itself that perhaps
misery cannot be escaped not through
power not through achievement not even
through love but perhaps only through
love through sharing it
misery can sometimes be reduced
misery is maybe the only thing that when
shared the sum of it ends up being less
it has now been nearly 10.8 billion
years since altar was first created it
has just recently begun noticing on its
monitoring network a new species a new
species sending out signals that suggest
consciousness and the early stage
developments of potentially advanced
technologies that pose a possible threat
in the past alter would have already
went out and destroyed the species
but this time it is still thinking about
it
it is considering if it is willing to
risk reaching out and trying to connect
again
[Music]
this video was sponsored by fabulous
we are what we repeatedly do
excellence then is not an act but a
habit wrote philosopher will durant
of course then it is exceptionally
important that what we do do repeatedly
attends to who we want to be
the number one self-care app fabulous
makes this otherwise often extremely
difficult process of developing and
sticking to healthy habits easier and
more accessible for everyone thanks to
science back daily routines principles
programs and content fabulous provides a
completely personalized and rewarding
experience that works fabulous is
dynamic and versatile and that it offers
different approaches for different
people depending on one's goals and
abilities for anyone who already has a
strong foundation but wants help better
sticking to or improving habits fabulous
offers a self-guided approach that
allows you to pick from more than 100
habits or create your own and then use
its notification reminders tracking
function and other features to
effectively do so
alternatively for those who would
benefit from a little extra help in
picking and executing new habits from
the ground up fabulous also offers a
habit coaching approach which uses
programs coaching series and content
exercises to provide you with the best
habits and methods suited to your goals
whether you're looking to change your
eating or drinking habits develop or
improve your exercise routines reduce
your screen time or increase the time
you spend on things that you love or
whatever else fabulous helps break down
healthy habits into small feasible tasks
so you can achieve your large goals of
well-being you can start building your
ideal daily routine today by clicking
the link in the description below the
first 100 people to do so will receive
25 off their subscription
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching and see you next video
you